لم تكن اوروبا مستعده لحرب على حدودها
وفاجاتها الحروب في اوكرانيا ولاجل ذلك
كان عاما صعبا على الاتحاد الاوروبي
والعالم وقع الحال هذا جاء على لسان رئيس
الشؤون الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيفوريل واوروبا هنا طبعا قيمت الواقع
المعقد في اوكرانيا ووجدت ان العالم منقسم
وسط صدام كبير بين القوتين العظمتين اي
الولايات المتحده من جهه والصين من جهه
اخرى وهي تريد وتسعى الى تحقيق السلام
العادل في اوكرانيا وهنا بدا لافتا جدا
حديث برال عن الدور الايجابي الذي يمكن ان
تلعبه الصين بهذا الخصوص بعدما اثبتت
الوقائع الميدانيه في حرب اوكرانيا بان
بكين لم تقدم اسلحه لروسيا حتى الان طبعا
هنا الحديث ليبرا دور الصين المهم والمؤثر
في انهاء الحرب الاوكرانيه تحدثت عنه ايضا
تحدث عنه طبعا ايضا وزير
الامريكيه الاسبق هريك سنجر لمجله نيوزويك
معتبرا انابيكين ستساعد في تغيير امد
الحرب بحلول نهايه العام وذلك عبر مفاوضات
سلام بين كل من روسيا واوكرانيا برعايه
طبعا بدات طلائع المكالمه الهاتفيه بين
الرئيس الصيني ونظيره الاوكراني لمده ساعه
افضل عن اجواء ايجابيه بين الرجلين فضلا
طبعا عن تعيين سفير لاوكرانيا لدى الصين
مما سيدفع بقوه لتنميه العلاقات الثنائيه
بين البلدين وفقا طبعا
وهنا لابد من الاشاره مشاهدينا بان سياسه
اوروبا تجاه الصين تغيرت نهائيا وشاهدنا
ذلك مع زياره الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانيال
ماكون الى الصين ورئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسولا فوندر لاين الى بكين
طبعا وقبلها زياره المستشار الالماني ور
ئيس الوزراء الاسبانيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات